speaking of business model which CEO
principles do you try to emulate your
own life or business plan after wow
great question um there's there's a
bunch of folks that I really admired
they're not all CEO some of them are
just thought leaders and authors and I
think Seth Godin is broadly and I think
Malcolm Adele and Malcolm Gladwell's
brilliant I think there's a lot of
really smart folks out there on the CEO
level I have to say it's funny because I
hide it I don't really appreciate the
experience that much but Howard Schultz
at starbucks one of the great lines I've
ever heard in an interview was when he
said to Charlie Rose what is this about
going into the music business why are
you selling CDs and Howard Schultz like
Emma said our customers have given us
permission to extend our brand I thought
that must be the single most genius line
of CEOs ever uttered on television and I
and I think that those innovators who
say well this is you know conquer shots
always only ever been a coffee shop and
all they do is serve coffee that's the
function I don't see the world that way
I'm going to change the rules those are
the people that I like those are the
people who are you know they they just
have an elliptical sort of creative
intelligence that allows them see
opportunity where others aren't seeing
it and they're doing things a little bit
differently you know we're seeing it in
even in the auto and things as
traditional as the auto industry Tesla
Tesla is an amazing i drove my first
Tesla the amazing experience right oh my
god so yeah there's a lot of people look
at it not for how charismatic they are
how or whether I like their personality
whether i like the sector the rent I
like to see people who cross lines
people who are disrupted in their
thought process we see it a lot in
technology you know certainly I think
Steve Jobs is you know got to be one of
those
for me about my first apple in 83 I've
never left since you know I've always
been loyal because I think part of the
ethos of that community is we're really
behaving differently because of what
they've created pretty cool pretty big
you